[Music]
I want to be here CU it's a scam it's a
case that should be immediately
dismissed the judge doesn't like when
President Trump explains what actually
happened because it's not good for his
narrative this is a judge who clearly
has an issue if you've seen his behavior
with me you've seen his behavior uh with
the president today he has a clear issue
with facts that are not good for the
case Trump's lawyer popping off as the
defiant defendant takes the witness
stand Donald Trump testifying in a high
stakes $250 million civil fraud trial in
New York which could lead to the
dismantling of his sprawling business
Empire it was a chaotic spectacle with
Trump repeatedly sparring with the
liberal judge who accused the former
president of holding a campaign rally
the judge even threatened to eject
Donald from the witness stand due to
what he deemed were nonresponsive
answers telling Trump's lawyers quote I
beseech you to control him if you can't
I will Dana uh are you happy or sad that
was this wasn't
televised one something on that in a
moment but have you ever used the word
beseech in a sentence in like in real
life only in the
bedroom well now you know America I
beseech you stop
snoring Gus Gus
exactly he does snore that little
monster okay so I I've been called a
traitor to my profession because I don't
think courtrooms should be televised I
am against it I think that it doesn't
necessarily help anybody in the
courtroom um I think that there's some
good reporting that goes on in the
courtroom and if you're president Trump
look at the sketches I mean they look
pretty good if you're president Trump
but I'm always against that I don't
think that adding cameras makes things
better for anybody and I think um if you
look at just what happened in the White
House briefing room from
1997 when Mike McCurry made the
briefings televised on the day that the
Lewinsky scandal broke by the way he
always thinks he wishes he could have
held it off a little bit longer I
realize everything is moving to video
but I like the tradition and the
solemnity of having it without can you
go back to that uh the the wide shot of
the uh of the yeah you can see there's
Lou CK over on the right hanging out I
guess he was going to be an uh be an
opener there Jesse he's basically the
most formidable candidate right now and
he's being do you get the feeling that
he's just being targeted they're just
yes Greg I get the feeling what a set up
what
a first of all I every time I hear the
word besch I'm GNA think of Greg in the
bedroom thanks a lot Greg Carrie kpek
who works for Fox is an excellent woman
she did great analysis she'll be on my
show tonight she said Leticia James the
New York attorney general is showing up
and just sitting in the back of this
courtroom all day long she's not even
arguing the case she's got a crime wave
she got Street crime wave she's got a
white collar crime wave and what is she
doing nothing she's just sitting in the
back of the courtroom every day watching
her lawyers argue the trial and then
she's giving a press conference and
calling the former president names what
a waste of time and the fact that no one
has ever prosecuted a case like this in
the history of New York State it's crazy
it's crazy it is crazy Harold what do
you have to say about Leticia James this
is about getting a scalp for her this is
personal this isn't really about her job
is it Harold well you know I I don't
know I followed this um in the in in the
press and I've and read a little bit of
it I read some of the Motions because I
was curious and there three three
takeaways I have from this first is I
don't think most people know that the
facts of this case have been settled
there the the judge gave granted summary
judgment which means he says that the
Attorney General's argument wins that
there has been fraud they appealed they
lost the appeal so this is about the
penalty phase and the only person who's
going to decide has any say so on what
the penalty is for president Trump is
the judge so I would probably come at
this a little differently I wouldn't be
criticizing the judge I might be
criticizing Leticia James for bringing
the case he has every right to do that
and he has every right to criticize the
judge to to a certain extent but I don't
understand why you would why you would
go after the judge as as viciously as he
is finally people are criticizing
Leticia James for being political and
for campaigning on the fact that she was
going to go after president Trump look I
don't think I'm like Dana on two things
one I'm old fashionate about the the
courtroom I don't think you should have
cameras in any of them and number two
I'm old fashion I don't think judges and
top prosecutors ought to be elected I
think they ought we ought to have a
different way of doing it because if
they get elected guess what they run on
an agenda yeah and she ran on an agenda
now president Trump when he ran for
office in 16 said I'm appoint judges
that gonna gonna undo abortion I didn't
necessarily agree with that he got
elected and guess what he did exactly
that so the politics of this doesn't
bother me as much as I think Jesse is
right I'm not sure how much this impacts
the president's Politics the real
question for him is will he ever be able
to do business in New York state again
because that could very well be the
penalty in this case all right Kaylee
what advice would you give him when he's
in the courtroom keep doing what he's
doing I mean look I would advise him to
ask for a better sketch artist because I
think he does not that does not look
like my former there um you know I would
just simply say this Leticia James to
call someone a conment and a Carnival
Barker then get elected then bring this
case then have a judge who says no I'm
not here to hear what president Trump
has to say you're the judge you have to
listen to what the defendant says this
is a travesty of Justice um and not
sketch travesty too it looks nothing
like drumk I don't know it's got a nice
jawline yeah his hands are quite sizable
I noticed that too never had a problem
in that department never had a
problem oh no up next liberal City
proving it can clean up a massive
homeless Camp after being sued hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else